this is my version of a controversial
title for a talk
so thanks thanks to the organizers and
everybody for having us here today I'm
going to this is kind of more of a like
this is what Carson is thinking about
right now set of slides and it just so
happens that it ties into our topic
about open data today so I'm gonna go
through and I'll try to link a few ideas
back to what some of my cope panelists
have talked about and then I'll try and
finish off maybe with some suggestions
for possible discussion topics once we
once we're finished so but before I do
that I'll tell you maybe why it's me I
should be here right you always have to
kind of justify your existence in
academia so that's what this slide is
about so I I'll admit to being a former
open sources elet I used to sort of say
if it's not if you're not using open
source and open data then you're not
doing science because if it's not
completely open people can't reproduce
what you're doing right and that's what
science is it's reproducible it's here's
what I did in order to answer this
interesting question and so you know I
used to sort of scoff it others who
weren't doing things in an open way and
I've sort of changed my perspective over
time and so I'll talk a little bit about
why my perspective has changed and some
of the people and ideas that have
influenced that and hopefully tie that
into this idea of openness okay so but
why I'm here I've worked on the hugest
open source GIS project since about 2007
so for those who are keeping track that
means I'm kind of like an open source
hipster right I wasn't there at the
beginning in the 90s when things were
really taking off but I got there kind
of early before was cool so I would
consider myself a an open source hipster
and particularly in terms of interacting
with the hugest project and the coolest
thing about the hugest project now is
that they don't need me anymore
so a lot of the things that I did at the
time developing a lot of the tools and
things that went into it I haven't
touched in years and they still exist
and they still get used by millions
actually of download
now every month for new versions or for
the latest version of kuja's and my name
is embedded in the code somewhere so
millions of times a month my name gets
downloaded on to someone's computer
which is pretty cool and in fact that's
actually want one thing I did want to
talk about in terms of openness and open
source and open data is it was probably
the smartest move I made career-wise
because it actually provides an
opportunity to interact with a lot
larger community of researchers and
individuals and things like that and so
I'll talk about this idea of open not
necessarily equating to access but
certainly at least promoting it so now I
work a lot of on geospatial Python
packages do a lot of programming in that
realm that's all open source stuff and
then recently I've been involved in
something called the enviro car data
project so this is a project where we
collect environmental data from people's
smartphones as they drive around and
it's like they involved here to do this
we're not just sneaking on people and
the environment data is made available
as open linked data so that any research
or a planner someone concerned with
urban environmental issues can use the
data it's completely anonymized and we
address a lot or we try to address a lot
of the issues with open data so I can
talk a little bit about that as well as
we get sort of further along but as I
said I was a former open source zealot
and this is probably what sort of
spawned that initial sort of reaction to
not being open so during my PhD I was
writing a paper and I wanted to make it
you know real science and I wanted to
tell people you know what sort of a
classification system I was using for
breaking up my data into different
classes and so I went online as you do
and try to Google for you know the
algorithm that was being used in the
software that I was using at the time
and since I guess we're not allowed to
say it's in their name today it's on the
screen there so you can figure so I
wanted to figure out what it was so I
looked at I found this forum post does
arcmap use the Jencks castle or the
Fisher Jenks algorithm for classifying
data into
Ricks seems like a pretty reasonable
question and potentially quite important
given that these two versions of the
algorithm produce different results and
so the response was and there were some
helpful responses and you know sort of
yeah we'd like to help you but that's
proprietary information along the lines
of a trade secret and so our policy is
that we don't share that so that was
very frustrating because now I'm going
to try and produce some research and I
can't actually tell anybody for sure how
I'm actually producing that research and
so I felt like this is not real science
this this is something so you know I
decided as a sort of someone who's in a
bit of a nerd I decided well I'll just
code up this algorithm myself yeah using
open source software and hey that's
great and everybody should do that
except that not everybody wants to do
that and so there's this sort of tension
here right that I I decided it was very
important for me to do that so I did it
and I published a paper and I could tell
you exactly what algorithm was used to
do the classification but this isn't an
issue or isn't a possibility for a lot
of people and so that's another issue of
openness I'd like to talk a little bit
about today and so that's kind of that
and some discussions actually at an a AG
workshop not that long ago year or two
ago about open GIS started getting me to
admit that maybe there are some it's not
this sort of yes or no open kind of
question there is a a continuum openness
and so this picture here is supposed to
suggest that over time along the road of
my career I discovered maybe there's
actually a sort of continuum of openness
right not everybody has to be able to
write their own algorithms in order to
be open in order to be doing some aspect
of open science open GIS using open data
so it's this continuum and I kind of
want to talk about that today as a
potential discussion topic and and I'm
not the only person who thinks about
these kinds of ideas there are lots of
you know lots of others talking about
this idea of openness and I'm talking
specifically about sort of the openness
of product sword-like so openness of GIS
openness of data openness of
collaboration there's a lot of different
ways that we can talk about this but in
the literature people like to have
letters that repeat alliteration is
always really great if you can do that
because it can drive your point home a
little bit better
comedians use it a lot as well and so
we've got this sort of big the four V's
of Big Data and we've got the four R's
of openness and so if you really want to
make an impact you need alliteration but
basically idea is that in order for
something to be open a resource be it
software data communication tool a
communication system it should be freely
available to others to reuse in
different contexts that's kind of like
the baseline requirement for something
to be open all right
even communication right you need to be
able to freely exchange ideas to others
and they need to be able to use those
ideas in other contexts to make pulse
right if I'm having a conversation with
someone then I need to be able to do
these things just as much as if I'm
going to be using a piece of software to
answer a question all right so the three
r's like recycling are to be able to
reuse revise remix and redistribute
things okay so this is this idea of the
three three r's of openness all right so
if we're using if we're talking about
software i should be able to reuse that
software i should be able to make some
changes to it
i should be able to combine that
software with something else and then i
should be able to share it with other
people in order so that they can see
what i'm what i'm thinking about and one
of the coolest things about the sort of
proliferation of GIS technologies over
the last few years has been this idea of
like every mixing different geospatial
data sources right and a lot of web
mapping technologies have really
facilitated this it started with sort of
hacking together bits and pieces of
google maps in order to show houses for
sale on a web map and now it's gotten to
the point where we have a lot of
different web mapping technologies a
bunch of different data people can mash
things together to answer some
interesting questions and one of the
other issues i'd like to talk about
today if we have time is this idea that
this is probably just a really great
thing right there are all of these open
data sources and open datasets or open
data or open source software components
out there and it means that a lot more
people are playing around with these
and most of them probably 99% of them
are not formally trained spatial
citizens and so they're producing pretty
weird stuff sometimes you know density
maps that aren't actually mapping
density and all sorts of things and at a
recent AAG conference there was some
people said well maybe we should take a
step back and say no like let's not let
all these people make these maps because
they're doing it wrong and I thought
that was a super scary thought
right this whole idea of openness is
that if we have a thousand really bad
maps and one good one that's much better
than a couple of good ones and nothing
else as far as I'm concerned so the idea
that the ability to reuse revise remix
and redistribute things in ways that
maybe aren't the smartest is still
produce useful results and allows
citizens who are not trained as laxmidas
talking about citizens who are maybe not
as trained as as professionals they can
still make an impact or potentially make
an event so that's another thing I'd
like to talk about but one of the kind
of interesting things I've seen since
being really angry during my PhD that I
couldn't get at this code - now is that
we really have seen a change in the
openness landscape in terms of software
in terms of data and in definitely in
terms of attitudes so it used to be that
I had to I had I have a colleague at
Esben I've had many conversations with
them you know oh yeah open-source
software is great and his sort of come
back to that was like well you know
prove it why is it better why is it
better than a proprietary system that's
you have to in order you have to be able
to justify that in order to say it's
better and my reaction to that is no I
don't think so actually
we as a society value transparency and
openness we clearly do otherwise we
wouldn't be promoting open data access
open and transparent government and
things like that so there is actually no
need to justify this idea of openness
and access to things it's a it's a thing
that we value as a society so it doesn't
need to meet the same criteria as a
proprietary software company as a
business model it's just a good idea
right so and I think that we've seen
that that sort of attitude change quite
a bit
in fact I have a number here numbers are
good
78% of companies now run on some form of
open source software so this is from
somewhere in their sort of software
stack or in their everyday business
model 78% this is there's this I you
know there's a source at the bottom if
you don't believe me 78% of companies
running an open source software and 65%
of Americans over the last year have
used online open data portals to access
information about their government right
which is you know 65% that's quite a lot
that's people who are interested in
accessing information in order to learn
something about the government I should
mention that only 5% of those people
think that their access is sufficient to
this type of information okay so lots of
people want to do it but most people
don't think it's good enough to do it
and so that brings me to this an
important idea which is structural
issues of openness so even if we make
something available online as a PDF
right it doesn't mean that we actually
have access to it and many of the people
who we want to have access to this
information don't have a degree in
computer science in order to parse the
CSV file and make a map and view it
online in the first place and there are
a bunch of communities particularly in
New York like this meetup group called
beta NYC who have lowered the barrier
for so many data sets in the city to the
point where most people can actually
interact with some data and that's
fantastic but that's something that I
think and laxmi was talking about this
as well that's something I think that we
really need to address now as an open
people interested in open data is now
the data is out there and that's great
right and now we have the software that
everybody can mix and match together but
not everybody has access to the skills
and ideas required so access to these
open products is not uniform by any
stretch of the imagination I can grab
some source code and modify it to look
at my at some particular geospatial
algorithm but my mom can't do that and
I'd still like her to be as informed
about what's going on in her community
as I am if I want to be right so here
are a few discussion points that we
could touch on that I've kind of touched
on a little bit in my class and you'll
notice that I have used a visual
style based on the least open
communication medium possible which is
an iPhone so there you go some little
bit of irony for you get in the
afternoon thanks very much
[Applause]